même s'il réside la moitié de l'année au
soleil ce couple de vendéens est inquiet
les retraités avaient prévu de quitter
nocibé ce mois de mai pour retourner
passer l'été dans leur région de
naissance comme ils le font chaque année
on n'est pas dans une prison leurs
obligations sont d'ordre médical ses
copains parce que du fait qu'elle ait
besoin de faire des raids avant des
rendez vous chez le ch et le docteur
tous les ans et
on ne peut pas partir et l'inconvénient
c'est qu'il réunit un conseil je suis
est limité à nocibé particulièrement
dans le cadre des cancers leur retour
doit donc se faire dans les plus brefs
délais le 2 mai vol oui depuis l'annoncé
de la fermeture des vols internationaux
le 20 mars dernier
quatre mille cinq cents ressortissants
français inscrits sur les listes
d'attentes ont pu regagner la france sur
une quinzaine de vols spéciaux juillet
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
rapporte d'avion et 1
voilà les premiers est-ce qu'on en
passant nettement le dernier vol spécial
a décollé ce 21 mai de tananarive
complet
à ce stade plus de 1500 français et
européens sont inscrits sur les listes
de signalements et 180 d'entre eux sont
considérés comme prioritaires sur le
plan médical
ces vols devront désormais suivre les
nouvelles règles fixées par le décret du
11 mai 2020 qui instaure la
distanciation physique dans les aéronefs
afin de préserver la santé des voyageurs
ce qui limite la capacité d'emport de
ses vols michel bâche l'euro est arrivé
sur l'île malgache le 21 février dernier
normalement je devais rentrer fin avril
pour les libertaires de mon petit fils
pour l'anniversaire de mon fils et mon
anniversaire
il est malheureusement pu circuler donc
le fut bloqué à 75 ans le retraité a
attrapé la fièvre typhoïde
cette infection potentiellement mortelle
due à une salmonelle lui a valu
plusieurs jours de convalescence sous
perfusion dans cet hôtel où il a trouvé
refuge et 7e qui rompt piémont gérer à
la clinique le choix est donc je réside
maintenant à l'hôtel et là je me sens
vraiment en famille donc je reste ici
j'ai refais mon visa jusqu'au mois de
juin 19 juin le septuagénaire ne s'est
pas encore inscrits sur les listes de
signalements depuis qu'il est guéri il
tente de patienter dans un esprit
positif
l'art voitures fermées donc ses fils y
déposer les avions des zones à haut
profil
moi je rêve de tout il veut mourir de
rire
bon voilà avoir tout le ferry à un rien
d'important
la seule chose importante est la santé
les deux uniques cas de covile 19 de
l'île de nocibé sont guéris depuis le
mois dernier la suspension des liaisons
aériennes internationales par les
autorités malgaches devraient durer au
moins jusqu'au 11 juin prochain
[Applaudissements]